nos piden que expresemos el área de todo
el rectángulo de abajo como un trinomio
tenemos este rectángulo por aquí abajo
que está dividido en estos otros tres
rectángulos y como podemos observar la
altura de todos los rectángulos es 4
pero el ancho por lo menos el ancho de
estos dos primeros rectángulos está
escrito en términos de x y bueno el
ancho de este último rectángulo es 2
así es que cuál es el área del
rectángulo completo te recomiendo que le
pongas una pausa y lo intentes por tu
cuenta
empecemos por aquí cuál es el área de
este pues se ve como un cuadrado pero le
podemos llamar rectángulo porque todos
los cuadrados son rectángulos bueno pues
el área de este rectángulo va a ser la
altura por el ancho así es que el área
de este rectángulo azul va a ser 4 x x
al cuadrado
4x
al cuadrado y a esta área le queremos
sumar el área de este otro rectángulo
rosa entonces va a ser 4 x 3 x 4 x 3 x
ahora 4 x 3 x cuánto es esto de aquí va
a ser 12 x cualquier porque tenemos 3 x
y lo multiplicamos por cuatro entonces
nos quedan 12 x entre 12 x si es que el
área de este rectángulo rosa es 12 x y
luego para sacar el área de este
rectángulo verde no vamos a necesitar
expresar lo en términos de la variable
porque lo podemos calcular directamente
ok su altura es 4 y su ancho es 2
entonces su área va a ser 8
ok
y ya terminamos